or mine was I go outside of the front
yard and go oh how come he has a dad
that's so cool
can you teach me how to play basketball
[Laughter]
[Music]
welcome back to another amazing episode
of the careful bull oh wow you guys have
not noticed we have with us our good
friend hoyan hey uh you look warm I'm
very warm he has a sweater and a soft
soft jacket a bubble jacket a bubbly one
Jay-Z in a 2002. oh that's a good that's
a good ERA for style thinking back to
your early teenage years
even you because you know now that
you're pretty fresh two years
your early teenage years when you were
very new to being like let's take like a
freshman in high school you're kind of
you don't know everybody you're kind of
unsure about yourself there's no
confidence what was something that you
were really envious about in someone
else
what Koreans you were envious of an
entire culture and race you wish I was
Korean what were they doing that was so
like there was just a lot of them wait
wait because when there was just a lot
of them that's why when I was younger
and I was Korean right I mean I've
always been Korean but like change now
yeah I'm Vietnamese he's trans ethnic
changes my way but like nobody knew what
Korean was like in Middle School what
everyone thought it was either Chinese
or Japanese no yeah that's right I grew
up all over the place because yeah we
moved around but I mean so your race is
all over the place
I guess so you didn't grow up with a
group of Korean friends because in
Southern California The Stereotype was
Korean stuck together but also there's
just so many that they can that's what I
heard I heard that like in California
it's like really populated yeah
everywhere I lived I was like the only
Korean there so there wasn't like a lot
of reference for like what Korean was
and he had to continually explain every
time he met new people so where I grew
up I grew up in Cerritos right and in
Cerritos there was uh the two cool Asian
groups were either Korean or Filipino
and there were maybe like two Chinese
people so you didn't Envy the Filipinos
huh Filipinos too Filipinos too so he's
just closer look yeah I'm closer I would
pass you're more I think the Filipinos
would look at me like you don't like you
don't have the talent you don't have the
melanin yeah but it was like a skills
there was like one Vietnamese guy like
two Chinese people and so it was like
those were the two major groups so
moving getting into freshman in high
school like the sense of belonging is so
important
you know and then yeah actually Koreans
were really good at having that KP you
know they had that like pride in their
groups you're coming in yeah
like that and the groups were so
specific too right there's like the
Korean like gang paste and there's like
the Korean like Trish people what's that
mean gangsters yeah
and there's like the Korean like Fabi
people like they're they're like very
clear sectors of Koreans but they were
like so they were so stand out yeah so
you were envying like what they had as a
group
or they're standing their respect
they're I think like when you were
younger there's less of like oh like
what's cool about me and how can I
contribute like you're not very
self-aware you would just see like a new
kid come into school and then it's like
hi my name is Eugene I'm a Korean and
it's like oh come over here are you okay
are you okay
I wish that happened to me and they're
like bro I've known you since
kindergarten and you've never given me
that love yeah you know I've known it
for [__] 14 years now and what the
[__] is that you never had a group yeah
yeah yeah versus just odd just like
automatic like oh okay they don't even
need to hear your name Korean people
will like scan the room and then they
just know like that's occur as soon as
you say oh my God yeah yeah and I was
like [__]
what's your name
oh my God oh my God they have the vowels
like even if they're not speaking Korean
they go like whoa
yeah yeah
very Hollow O's
Korean syllables that's nice that's
funny too like automatic you're just
like you're you're in a group you don't
stand out you got people to hang out
with during lunch time you're not like
trying to figure [__] out you know yeah
did you envy any items or possessions
other people had when you were a
teenager yeah money money just just
straight up money
motorcycles and cars
and somebody shows up in a nice car
that's such [__] swag they park in
the parking lot and [__] like that and
it's unattainable by any like personal
means my friend bought a Honda CRX for
600 bucks and everyone was like dude now
you could give everybody a ride and
you're gonna get laid
[Laughter]
like we were we did
we did [__] Rich Koreans outside the
hills again with the Koreans and the
nice cars yeah right so like you know
we're some us regular Asians have showed
up with like some Civics and stuff and
Integris that's just what it was right
and these [__] are showing up
in like Jaguars and [__] benzes the
ones that Fullerton yeah and it was just
wild it was I think we have a Korean
honorary Korean no way we do plus you go
plus when you got to do these like group
projects
the [__] Koreans why do you say
honorary Korean
oh look how Korean this guy is oh my God
oh my God oh my God what's up
what the [__] are you
that's so rude call me a man we're
filming we're filming and Bart's telling
us how jealous he is of Koreans really
yeah because he was still filming right
now we're filming right now we're
filming right now and he wished he was
Korean are you guys behind you don't
have to say hi to me though you can say
hi to everybody in the room with me
[__] piece of [__] hey [__] Anthony
let's start this video
this guy gets the Beats of the show two
Koreans or all right we're on the
believable Korean side of the younger
one so he gets the big chair oh that's
so Korean
we're talking about my name's Jason by
the way I don't care
[Laughter]
okay we were talking about how like in
your early teenage years before you were
confident about anything like freshman
going to high school what were you
envious about in other people in black
people or black
their knees their strength their speed
they make really good barbecue
like in other people
so do we
yeah barbecuing and Grilling
no guys that had like cars and bikes and
everything that like because even like
the poor kids like if they're like they
were like their dad was like a mechanic
or whatever right they'll put together
like a little more bike or something at
fifth grade and so you'll see like this
fifth sixth grader like already like
riding [__] dirty in the motorcycle
and I'm like man oh you know what I
wanted [__] I wanted [__]
puberty dude yeah that's all I wanted
yeah I was [__] 14 like [__] five
one hey me too oh you were late bloomer
yeah and I want to see [__]
like like I'm trying to like hey where
you from trying to stop the
[__] and [__] and then there's
fools with grown men bodies you know
like Adam's Apple all sticking out
smoking cigarettes and I'm like man I'm
Junior High in high school still
this one grew up so poor that's what
poor people care about the [__]
over here smoking cigarettes and [__] he
just wanted height you know what I
wanted the crossfire thing remember
you're the [__] rich kids in the
neighborhood had crossfires they had the
Super Soakers with multiple nozzles
like eight years old I was I was this
fight
this hype when I was 14. so this is
crazy wow yeah so I was like I was
trying to break 100 pounds that's what I
wanted to do I broke 100 pounds when I
was three
I was so I was six feet when I was 14
and then I grew another inch when I was
like in college I'm with like six one
after that but I I was told by the
doctor I was supposed to be six three
and he [__] lied oh how would he know
though they couldn't guess right can't
they guess like with taika I don't think
so
it's [__] dude
there's a guy you'll be 60 years old
he guessed I think they do that thing
where they can see how tall you're gonna
be or some [__] right if you were six
foot when you were one 14 he was like oh
yeah you got plenty more I was like yeah
yeah [__] in the when you're a freshman
in high school I'm not sure if they do
it like now but they would throw
freshman in the garbage cans and [__]
like that right oh yeah I don't know
what that [__] was about but I was so
fat nobody could lift me up so I [__]
killed it kind of an advantage it was
easy so like they would always pick the
smaller people but I was so big nobody
everybody left me alone it took like
five of them they're just like I only
give up no but physical bullying they
just like talk [__] about each other on
Instagram stories how old are you
um
right yeah you got your dick sucked yet
what's up bro
man himself
yeah you look really Korean though oh
really yeah I don't know if that's a
company I could racially abuse you
you say he hasn't even grown up Korean
huh he said he doesn't even grow doesn't
know what it's like to be around because
he grew up all over yeah my dad was in
the military so we moved around like
every four years so I heard California
like all the Koreans stick together but
no man I didn't have a lot of creams in
my neighborhood either so I only started
hanging out with a lot more Korean
people when I got here Ellie's very very
[__] Korean like if you go to K-Town
there's people who grew up in Cape Town
that are full-fledged American never
been to Korea can't speak English have
Korean accent and can't speak they can't
speak Korean or English well
there are no males
yeah AKA dumbfounded yeah can't speak
anything right not even Spanish or
whatever the [__] the one guy you choose
is a Lyricist yeah yeah yeah only when
he rhyme if his rhyming is good
otherwise
dump out his skin is so nice now he's be
like using lotion and [__] he'd be
taking a lot of selfies and stuff now
little [__] dude what's up that's it JK
news he just uses lotion and his skin
got nice and it's a [__]
I don't know David your skin looks
really nice right now very Immaculate oh
you didn't know that and you always had
nice skin though you got a Korean sauce
I started having nice skin when I met
Muriel because she's the one that said
my skin looked like trash so every time
every time we would go out she's like oh
you should put on lotion I'm like this
[__] gay I don't I don't think I know
Kareem with bad skin oh yes you do cool
my brother
my brother's getting [__] terrible
that's because he works in the hospital
so they always force you to wear masks
so his acne has been going crazy my mom
used to call him this funny ass nickname
it's uh yodram which means it's like
pimple professor
[Laughter]
that's a very hard thing to clap back
from is when you have bad skin someone
hits you for that it's hard to like
what's the question I got nothing for
him he's got to be like you made me
teach me how yeah he had really really
bad skin I remember when I was 14 and he
was like a senior in high school I
started calling him I used to get pissed
and then I started having acne he goes
and I started crying I was like no
pimple Apprentice simple Apprentice I
got it from you Dad yeah
back to the top you know it took me a
long time to get that everybody else in
my school got [__] TI-83 Plus oh the
good calculator bro
don't you need that for class or
whatever but yeah she's like 100 bucks
yeah it was still expensive call you a
Tilly's Paxon wait why are you jealous
of a calculator he was asking about what
are you envious of at the time and
everybody's [__] playing like [__]
Phoenix 2 and [__] snake and random
[__] and the drug yeah that actually
just plays games no but you can use that
in class people had them in class so
you're sitting in [__] class and if
you couldn't afford this 150 calculator
or whatever the [__] you're sitting
there with your regular ass calculator
were you were you ever jealous of people
with calculators
I think I was jealous of people that had
guns
all right
[Laughter]
when you're 14 right like at that time
like all like all you had or who your
homies were oh this guy got back from
this person or this one this was
connected this guy and you're like man
you're just trying to make it in this
[__] tough world the [__] student
body and then you're [__] like five
one 90 pounds you're just like man I
need I need a I need something maybe
it's because you're walking around
school like this now
[Laughter]
yeah I remember that calculator being a
big deal though no no [__] the gay ass
calculated conversations go straight to
guns give me a gun or a growth spurt
something that'd be cool I'll check
either Dude any any one of those things
but the cars thing was a big deal too
there were kids with M3s when I was in
high school yeah
but they were like
you're right like when I got to this
neighborhood Monterey Park some of the
Chinese kids had nice cars and I was
like
how did you get that I think I was
jealous of anybody who could drive yeah
right because like the most the most
popular people in our school were the
ones that had the band so like any event
like the [__] the Chevy Astro the
[__] it doesn't matter
we'll just [__] open the doors and
[__] ghost ride that [__] at you know
that was fun yeah it was super [__]
fun and then the person with the van is
the one that we could monitor them all
with and everything else do you remember
you guys have to like trunk it yeah like
if you don't have enough space you're
like if you want another homie I just
[__] always dude always
damn the struggle I feel like cops deal
with that every generation too they
always catch people are still trucking
it now oh yeah oh yeah yeah yeah people
are doing like that Hoodrat stuff yeah
it's fun even if you don't have to now
it's not by necessity we did it because
of fun right oh the whole back seat's
empty and everyone
you prefer the truck
yeah was everybody poor growing up in
this room yeah I was poor but I knew of
rich kids oh I didn't have that
everybody was poor around so I didn't
know what I was missing right so when
you're poor when everybody's poor around
you everybody's just the same I would
rather that because my [__] thing is
when we would go to group projects or
something like and then it's like oh you
guys come to my house and then everybody
goes to some [__] korean's house in
like Coyote Hills or some [__] in
Fullerton and they got like a mansion
compared to what you got you're like my
parents suck well there's also there's
also the feeling of like when there's a
generational Gap with Asian Americans
there's so many unjustifiable expenses
that your parents are like we don't need
that you know what I mean like even if
it's just for school it'll be like no we
don't need that oh you need to punch
money you [__] yeah
drink water so you can cry more
it'll feature for life or mine was like
go outside of the front yard and go oh
how come he has a dad that's so cool
can you teach me how to play basketball
back in the day at JK we used to play
basketball after every like JK news
right this [__] dude it would be
tackling the [__] out of people man he's
so [__] wide right whenever he would
drive everybody kind of get the [__] out
the way I really wish you did have it
would teach you how to play basketball
his wife would be clotheslining people
and this will just got it he just lace
it up he has the point he gets 100
points
that's a hundred [__] points man I
think we all heard we got it at home
already when you're at the marketing
[__] you're like I want that that's your
class I want that you know we have it at
home already we'll make it out I want
McDonald's like no we have hamburger
patties at home sad replica and then at
home it's like I get the I get like the
[__] wheat bread with the Roman guy
and then my grandma puts like a
hamburger patty in the middle there
the Kraft slice the cheese and that's my
McDonald's that sounds pretty [__]
good though man I was smash one right
now yeah my mom's used to do that you
know those you'll see it now while they
do Fusion words like Korean barbecue
patties they'll put the Korean Korean
barbecue marinade inside like ground
beef and they'll make a Patty out of it
my mom was doing that since I was a
little kid oh damn and I remember when I
was a kid I used to hate that [__] I'm
like you better stop making that goofy
ass [__] Burger I want that American
[__] take all that [__] get garlic and
soy sauce out my goddamn [__] Burger
get that [__] burger out of here what
the [__] is this what am I the [__]
monster [__] out of here so my mom
so I remember one time my mom made the
burgers for me and my friends right and
I was so upset I'm so embarrassed what
was this [__] ching chong [__] man
I'm gonna put [__] kimchi inside this
[__] but that's what people do now and I
remember specifically yeah my friends
ate it and they're like dude this is the
best thing ever I was like whoa yeah man
my mom is tied
Burgers anymore
but that's like when you're a kid you
always want what other people have
like the Wonder Bread white boy
sandwiches the the hand yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah you would trade for
that if it doesn't get stuck on the roof
in your [__] mouth man the bread
whatever I eat the [__] sandwich you
get stuck to the roof of the mouth but
that's the best part though especially
when you got braces so it stays there
for a while oh I never have braces man I
had to Mason teaches I was a kid that's
an interesting thing though being an
envious of other kids lunches yeah maybe
not in the teen years but that was
elementary school for sure yeah peanut
butter and jelly sandwiches my mom never
made me any of those anything that was
like white simple and cheap uncooked hot
dogs you know what I'm saying those
[__] white people snacks right
there was a kid named Ryan I
specifically remember it used to always
eat uncooked hot dogs just out of a
Ziploc bag not even out of the Ziploc
bag though he would bring the whole
[__] the whole Hebrew National but
yeah and then he would cut it open like
with his fingers like this and the juice
would all come out
and he just sat in there [__] chew on
a hot dog he would just be sitting next
just sitting down a recess and eat the
rawhawks
it's cooked already I think so hot dogs
are already cooked same thing with Spam
you could eat all that stuff that sounds
like something black though dude
honestly spam when I was a kid sometimes
that should be bomb yeah I used to eat
raw Spanish not like the whole can but
like you know you know when like you
like pull out the Spanish cook it and
you're like still hungry and [__] like
it's not even done cooking you haven't
seen people like drink spam juice oh God
the OG spam though had the the gelatin
yeah like that that thick gel like the
dog food like when you take it out of
the can it's still got that jelly yeah
yeah yeah yeah
the new ones just has juice now it's
just like glistening fat and Juice yeah
it's like liquefied all the way like
jello like actual like gelatin
byproducts you're not meant to be there
but it's like it's like fat byproduct no
it's from being sealed in there it's
from like cartilage and all that like
connective tissue and stuff so it'll
congeal when it gets cold yeah so so
even when you when you like cook fish
right like you'll see after you leave it
over you see that little gelatin yeah
and that's the same meaning that you
would see inside that spam because it's
just like pork by-product and people
would take that and just kind of cook it
down because it's just natural grease
anyways flavor but there's a lot of
people who hate spam man and I still
don't understand that [__] really stem
is bummed Andrew Zimmer yeah Bizarre
Foods hate spam that's weird and this
will eat dick he legit eats anytime he
goes to a new country he goes where's
the penis and then he chews on that
so let me find a dick did you guys see
this episode of Bizarre Foods where he
went he went to Cambodia and there's
this dish that I was like it's very rare
that I'll see something that I'm like
maybe be I won't try like I always will
try something once but I guess in
Cambodia they eat these large tarantulas
like literally oh yeah yeah this size
but it's like in a dirt right it's in
the dirt yeah I saw that one and he this
[__] dude just grabs it and he
eats it like it's the most delicious
thing he's ever had in his life
and then like it cuts to another episode
where he's like this lady in China he
takes him to eat this like cake he bites
into it then he goes oh what
[Laughter]
of like an art house Cinema lover
oh God that movie was amazing oh bullet
train sucks
like it has to be that I don't know what
it is it has to be that because I don't
understand what the problem with Spam I
think spam's delicious do you see the
one where he had to go to a restaurant
in Hawaii that specializes in all Spam
no oh he must have I think it was Maui
or big island but the whole place is
like they have so many different things
on the menu and one after the other they
were just giving them Spanish like no no
but it makes sense to why he can eat all
this crazy [__] he was actually homeless
like living out in the streets really so
his story is actually pretty dark so
wouldn't that make Spam pretty light
yeah yeah that would have been homeless
at all that's why he's out here in
[__] Vietnam eating like Duck ass and
it's just like oh I have a palette for
[__] now yeah so he was he said he was
literally eating out of garbage can
because he was that poor sometimes
you're spamming garbage
maybe I'm more likely they're spamming
that garbage can but I really do miss
that show though because it got canceled
I know one of my favorite favorite food
shows of all time just to watch a white
person eat Asian [__]
foreign